as far back as I could remember I always
wanted to be a gangster one of a
thousand working stiffs until it wasn't
no more while the Irishman stands on its
own as a powerful meaningful film I
think it's full significance is felt
within its context - Martin Scorsese's
earlier movies the Irishman has thematic
and stylistic overlap with everything
from taxi driver to Raging Bull to
casino but in this video I want to focus
specifically on the ways the Irishman
builds on elements of Goodfellas and
what we can learn about the Irishman by
comparing how similar scenes and
techniques are used in both films thanks
to movie for sponsoring this video go to
movie comm slash Thomas flight to get
your extended free trial let's start at
the beginning with the Irishman's
opening scene this long Steadicam
tracking shot is undeniably reminiscent
of two shots from Goodfellas first this
very famous tracking shot
[Music]
and this slightly less famous
perspective tracking shot and then there
was Moe blacks brother fat Andy and his
guys Frankie the [ __ ] and the Irishman
the cameras movements and the music act
as callbacks to these shots from
Goodfellas and Mikey franchisee but the
differences here are where the thematic
significance lies while this shot
elevates the life of gangsters to
something epic energetic and sweeping
this shot is searching wandering and
empty the camera is slower it's less
steady it almost hobbles its way to its
destination the main character and our
narrator in a wheelchair while this shot
from Goodfellas invokes the community of
mob life and you had Nicky eyes this
shot searches for a familiar face and
finds none
[Music]
in Goodfellas Scorsese is using these
tracking shots to give us a cinematic
view of a gangster in his prime reaping
all the benefits that come with his
lifestyle by using the same technique to
illustrate a gangster alone at the end
of his life Scorsese is drawing extra
attention to the emptiness and fleeting
nature of those benefits and to the
different perspective that the Irishman
will be taking on it's subject matter
this opening shot sets up the Irishman
as something distinct from Goodfellas
how truly different it is won't be clear
for almost another three hours of the
film but this start strongly indicates
to the audience they're stepping on to a
different kind of ride another stylistic
technique that Scorsese uses in both
films is the freeze-frame
in Goodfellas the freeze frames are used
to help construct Henry's personal
mythology around himself and people he
knew see Jimi was one of the most feared
guys in the city he was first locked up
at 11 and he was doing hits for mob
bosses when he was 16 in the Irishman
the freeze frames are used to introduce
characters but they come with the
addition of a title card telling us how
the character died you took care of
everything from Philadelphia to Atlantic
City that I know
there's an emphasis on death and past
tense even in the character
introductions it's a shift in narrative
perspective from Henry's in Goodfellas
as someone who still idolizes the
lifestyle and the mythos for us to live
any other way was nuts to Frank's in the
Irishman someone who's alone reminiscing
at the end of his life but that's
another thing I want I don't want to get
into after all these people have died
the structure of both films is built
around a penultimate sequence that
precedes an epilogue in both films these
scenes cover the events of a single day
closely but stylistically Scorsese
approaches these scenes very differently
[Music]
we're the scene in Goodfellas is frantic
filled with cocaine paranoia intense
music and fast edits
the scene in the irishman is calm
deliberate and quiet this time instead
of using a similar stylistic choice to
draw attention to the connection between
different scenes across the two films
uses a different stylistic approach to
emphasize the difference between two
scenes that have a similar structure and
this is where the audience can begin to
feel the full weight of how the
perspective shifts between the film's in
Goodfellas this scene is the climax of a
combination of music editing and
voiceover that have given the film so
much of its energy in the irishman all
of these things fall away and we're left
with a stark view of the events that are
taking place there's a visual mirroring
between Jimmy Hoffa's final moments and
Tommy's and Goodfellas each movie ends
with a betrayal but again the
differences are stark while Henry is on
the side being betrayed in Goodfellas
and the Irishman Frank is the one
betraying
if you line the two films up it's not an
accident that Goodfellas ends right
about where the Irishman's final act
kicks off because the Irishman's final
act extends thematically beyond where
Goodfellas ends the Irishman is the
gangster film stripped of its use of
anything that glorifies the life and
Goodfellows Henry has lived the life he
always wanted to live and escapes
relatively unscathed and the Irishman
Frank gets his life but that's almost
all he gets there's a link between the
ending of Goodfellas and the beginning
of the Irishman at the end of
Goodfellows Henry who has been narrating
for the entire time speaks his narration
directly to the audience and then I need
to blow the winnings in a week or go to
the Sharks to pay back the bookies
didn't matter anything this moment
contextualizes the film and the
narration as a sort of confession from
the witness stand in the Irishman
there's a similar moment but it happens
at the beginning of the film in business
agent for teams to local 107 iris apfel
II one of a thousand working stiffs
attila wasn't no more I think this is a
deliberate choice that signifies that
the Irishman is picking up where
Goodfellas left off somatically Henry
confesses to the audience but he does so
to save his own skin and the Irishman
Frank's confession to the audience is
not an attempt to save himself from the
law or from getting whacked it's over
they're all gone it's an attempt to save
his soul can I pray with me again yeah
Henry gets redeemed in the eyes of the
law but it's a sort of false Redemption
his only regret is that he had to give
up the life an average nobody get to
live the rest of my life like a schnook
whether Frank can find true Redemption
or if that's even possible is the larger
spiritual question
Scorsese asks at the end of the Irishman
Martin Scorsese has recently been very
vocal about how cinema is changing a lot
of great art films are losing their
space and theaters and are moving on to
streaming services movie comm is one of
the great streaming services that is
giving these kinds of art films a home
they have a hand curated collection of
30 films at a time you get access to a
new film every day they have great art
house films international cinema
exclusives
and festival pics one of the things I
love about movie is that every movie
they put in their catalog comes with a
brief explanation of why they chose that
film it's a great way to discover
something new and interesting that you
wouldn't see anywhere else and you can
try it now for free for 30-days when you
go to movie.com slash thomas flight
check it out FM ubi com slash Thomas
flight thank you so much for watching
special thank you to my patreon
supporters but at patreon.com slash
Thomas plate to find out how you can
support my channel
[Music]